hablamos de salud en directo américa de
france al 24 ya está lista entonces en
nuestra mesa de trabajo marina sardiña
para hablar marinado un experimento que
resucita los órganos de cerdo son
muertos con sangre artificial en qué
consiste entonces este estudio marina
bueno raúl resucitó parcialmente pero si
es algo que ha dejado atónitos a los
investigadores no digamos que los
investigadores los estudios científicos
advierten que los hallazgos aún no son
clínicamente relevantes aunque plantean
muchas cuestiones raúl la investigación
fue publicada en la revista nature los
científicos restauraron la circulación y
la actividad celular en los órganos
vitales de los cerdos como el corazón o
los riñones que cuando se detiene la
circulación sanguínea la oxigenación es
irreversible nos morimos raúl y
comisionó mestre esto pues mira hubo
tres grupos de cerdos a los que se le
provocaron un paro cardiaco tras una
hora sin riesgo sanguíneo es decir
muertos el grupo uno de los grupos lo
conectaron a un sistema de soporte vial
usado en graves en los que el corazón o
los pulmones dejan de funcionar a otro
grupo lo dejaron en un grupo de control
sin técnicas de reanimación y un tercer
grupo lo conectaron a un sistema
tecnológico innovador llamado organics
que bombea la sangre artificial por todo
el cuerpo de los animales una especie de
súper sangre sintética raúl que se tras
que se traspasa de un azul que se trata
de perdón de una solución que contenía
sangre de los animales y 13 compuestos
como anticoagulantes la base de éste es
de nuevo a técnica orgánica es la
hemoglobina una proteína que
transportaba el oxígeno pero de forma
modificada aunque los cerdos no
recuperaron la conciencia el
procedimiento ralentizó la
descomposición de los cuerpos y restauró
algunas funciones de los órganos vitales
como decíamos esto es lo que nos dijo el
estudio
los investigadores notaron que los
hígados de los cerdos orgánicos
producían mucha más proteína llamada
albúmina que los hígados de los cerdos
de otros grupos y las células en cada
uno de los órganos vitales de los cerdos
orgánicos respondieron a la glucosa
mucho más que los animales en otros
grupos lo que sugiere que el tratamiento
había reactivado el metabolismo hablamos
marina de lo más novedoso del estudio y
lemas éticos que plantea esta
investigación
gracias a esta sangre artificial
organics como decíamos los científicos
de la universidad de yale observaron que
neuronas y astro cítrico y a los
trocitos por ejemplo en dos regiones del
cerebro del cerebro recuperaron su
estado previo a la isquemia también
detectaron actividad eléctrica en el
corazón como la capacidad de contraerse
además algunos órganos volvían a tomar
la glucosa presente en la sangre
artificial los mismos investigadores
advirtieron que estamos muy lejos de
utilizar esta técnica en órganos humanos
y en personas humanas pero podrían
mejorar las técnicas de los trasplantes
de órganos pues en su conservación sobre
todo a la hora de ser trans planta 2 y
plantea también raúl o algunas
cuestiones morales y éticas en cuanto al
significado de la muerte especialmente
si la técnica pudiera algún día
restaurar la actividad cerebral después
de la muerte ayer miércoles marina
cambiando de información eeuu declaró
lario la del mono como emergencia de
salud pública le pregunto qué significa
esto si es que raúl eeuu ya es el primer
país con mayor número de contagios por
viruela química ya superó los mil los
siete mil 100 contagios por viruela del
mono y tiene presencia en 48 estados
todavía no hay ningún fallecido en el
país esto hay que aclararlo pero si las
autoridades debido a la rápida expansión
del virus decidieron declarar la
emergencia de salud pública en todo el
país hasta ahora sólo algunos estados
como nueva york o heliópolis estaban
declarando esta emergencia de salud
pública y que supone esta declaratoria
bueno raúl lo que supone es lo primero
es que tienen mayor acceso a las a los
fondos a las vacunas para y a otros
recursos federales para responder a este
nuevo brote de viruela química por
ejemplo un mayor acceso a vacunas contra
la viruela del mono
recordemos según las meses solo hay 16
millones de vacunas en todo el mundo
entonces hay una gran pelea a nivel
mundial por estas dosis en eeuu se
conoce la vacuna como guineo sólo hay
unas tiene otro nombre distinto en el
resto de el mundo pero en eeuu 2 es la
vacuna de guineos incluso los expertos
en salud están un poco observando y
considerando nuevas técnicas para que
esta para enfrentar esta escasez de
vacunas como por ejemplo compartir dosis
de una vía al que la misma vacuna guinea
se pueda dividir en hasta 5 dosis
separadas para repartirlas a distintas
personas o la forma en la que se
administra este suero como por vía
intradérmica o subcutánea además de
declarar la emergencia también
anunciaron que habrá más de 600.000
dosis de guineos disponibles para un
total de 11 millones de inyecciones para
finales a mediados de septiembre y
14.000 tratamientos con tipo que un
medicamento que es un antiviral que
ayuda a paliar los síntomas de la
viruela del món de marina como siempre
muchísimas gracias por toda la
información de salud de buen fin de
semana también para usted saluda realiza
mentes para hablar de deportes